en el vídeo anterior probamos el
lanzador y nos dimos cuenta de que
muchas veces el lanzador tiraba las
pelotas hacia la izquierda ahora veremos
si podemos arreglarlo como pueden ver
analizamos algunos componentes clave que
marcamos de color rojo que son el
tornillo de bloqueo de 5 dieciseisavos y
la plataforma de pvc que sujeta la
pelota ahora lo que pasa es que cuando
jalamos la barra hacia atrás la pelota
también va hacia atrás junto con la
barra y al soltar la barra la pelota va
junto con ella hasta que la barra choca
contra el bloqueo y la pelota sale
disparada entonces queremos ver si
podemos quitar ese tornillo y la
plataforma una razón es porque el
tornillo es un punto fijo que puede
crear tensión en un punto específico de
la barra de aluminio y esa tensión
incluso puede cambiar la estructura
cristalina del metal y con el tiempo
hasta puede ser que se rompa en algún
momento entonces vamos a ver si podemos
lanzar la pelota pero usando la misma
técnica
usa un pateador de fútbol americano en
ese caso hay alguien deteniendo la punta
del balón y el pateador corre hacia él y
patea el balón en lugar de que el balón
vaya con él todo el tiempo así que
instantáneamente cuando entra en
contacto con el balón que está siendo
detenido en un cierto punto el balón es
lanzado entonces pensamos que sería
interesante diseñar un dispositivo que
pudiera sostener la pelota en su lugar
como el jugador que detiene el balón
para el pateador se nos ocurrió que
podíamos usar un clip y doblarlo para
crear un dispositivo como este que se
muestra en morado para sostener la
pelota en su lugar de esta manera
podemos quitar la plataforma y el
bloqueo y también mejorar la precisión y
la seguridad del dispositivo empecemos
con la pelota la colocamos en su
posición y con unas pinzas abrimos el
clip y lo moldeamos para crear un
círculo grande en un extremo y uno
pequeño en el otro así la forma del clip
ahora será como la de una letra c cuando
lo vemos con
en el dispositivo tomo un poco de tiempo
saber exactamente en donde colocarlo
aquí hacemos un orificio en un lado de
la madera y vamos a poner un tornillo
para sostener el clip en su lugar y al
final del clip en el círculo que hicimos
podemos poner un tornillo para sujetarlo
ahora una vez que tenemos el clip en su
lugar ponemos la pelota y nos aseguramos
de que esté alineada correctamente para
que pueda ser lanzada todavía tenemos la
plataforma de pvc porque aun queremos
experimentar con eso de todas formas la
quitaremos porque al final aún con el
clip provocaba una desviación en el
lanzamiento aquí haremos un lanzamiento
rápido para verificar que sí funcione
sí
decidimos hacer algunas pruebas y
registramos las distancias y alturas así
como los diferentes ángulos y posiciones
en que lanzamos la pelota
hicimos esto varias veces y también
pusimos una trampa de arena para saber
exactamente en donde caía la pelota y lo
registramos entonces como tratamos de
mejorar el lanzador en todos los
sentidos nos dimos cuenta de que había
un par de cosas para mejorar así que
regresamos al diseño e hicimos las
adaptaciones
finalmente y analizando nuestro diseño
descubrimos que si lanzábamos en un
ángulo más pronunciado como en este caso
cuando colocamos el lanzador con un
ángulo de 50 grados 60 y 80 grados la
parte superior del dispositivo estaba
inestable entonces cuando lanzamos la
pelota de ping pong era difícil hacer un
lanzamiento sin que esa parte se moviera
otra cosa que observamos fue que cuando
queríamos sostener el lanzador para
estabilizarlo lo agarra vamos de aquí lo
cual estaba bien excepto por el hecho de
que cuando la barra de aluminio regresa
podía llegar a golpear nuestra mano en
esta parte así que quisimos asegurarnos
de que no existiera esa posibilidad y
buscamos una forma de poder mantener
esta parte en su posición así que
decidimos incorporar o crear estas
mejoras aquí tenemos un tornillo que
cortamos un poco y es un tornillo de 5
dieciseisavos con un aditamento de nylon
alrededor eso evitará que la parte
superior del lanzador se mueva
hacia atrás cuando lo tengamos en un
ángulo pronunciado y también usamos una
placa de madera de media pulgada para
crear una tapa y así cubrir esta área
del resorte en la que haremos un
orificio para que podamos accesar a ese
tornillo por sí necesitamos ajustarlo o
aflojarlo y también haremos un hueco
pero para este tornillo de esta forma
podemos usar el lanzador sin lastimarnos
entonces estas son las mejoras que
implementaremos en el lanzador
se los giramos un poco para que lo
puedan ver desde diferentes ángulos y
como pueden ver agregaremos 1 2 3 4
piezas principales de madera para formar
la cubierta y también el tornillo con su
aditamento ok ahora vamos a ver qué
podemos hacer para mejorar el lanzador y
vamos a incorporar esos cambios ahí ya
pueden ver el tornillo con el aditamento
en su lugar para evitar que el lanzador
se regrese y ahora vamos a medir la
parte de arriba de la cubierta que irá
sobre el área del resorte será de 6
pulgadas y media de ancho y usaremos una
broca plana de una pulgada para perforar
los orificios para acceder al tornillo
del centro y al del resorte entonces
marcamos las posiciones perforamos los
orificios limpiamos todo y vamos a poner
una cerca para que al usar la sierra
circular podamos hacer un corte derecho
y pusimos la placa de madera así para
asegurarnos de que la cerca no
interfiriera con las prensas
ahora simplemente acortamos la longitud
y limpiamos los bordes con la lima ahora
vamos a cortar las placas que irán en
los lados son de una pulgada y tres
cuartos de ancho y armarán la caja las
limpiamos dos son de 6 pulgadas y media
de largo y hay una pieza de 13 pulgadas
de largo que es la que irá en la orilla
entonces primero sujetamos la pieza en
su lugar ya habíamos hecho las marcas a
tres octavos del borde y ahora vamos a
perforar los orificios con una broca de
un dieciseisavo y después colocamos los
tornillos que son de una pulgada y media
atornillados también la pieza de arriba
y ahora vamos a poner la pieza de abajo
la alineamos usando las prensas y
nuevamente marcamos a tres octavos de
pulgada del borde y colocamos los
tornillos ahora vamos a poner la parte
de arriba hacemos las perforaciones y
colocamos los tornillos ya que teníamos
todo puesto nos dimos cuenta de que el
orificio del centro no estaba tan limpio
como nos gustaría
así que usamos una lijadora para darle
un mejor acabado ahora quitamos la tapa
para ensamblar todo lo que va por dentro
del dispositivo y esto ya lo habíamos
hecho antes así que no hay nada nuevo
apretamos bien los tornillos para que
todo quede fijo y después ajustamos
todos los tornillos de la nueva cubierta
del lanzador
ahora estamos acortando el tornillo que
necesitamos que era el tornillo
representado de color verde en el diseño
y lo limpiamos con la lima ahora vamos a
asegurarnos de que la parte de arriba no
se regrese cuando la tengamos en un
ángulo pronunciado al usar esto por acá
tenemos el tornillo que habíamos puesto
primero también tenemos el clip que
sujetará a la pelota en su lugar y
nuevamente podemos comprobar que al
bajar la placa de arriba
el dispositivo queda completamente plano
aquí lo estamos girando para que puedan
ver los diferentes componentes y como se
ve todo junto
entonces vamos a colocarlo en un cierto
ángulo ponemos el tornillo de ángulo y
ponemos el otro tornillo con el
aditamento ahora haremos una prueba de
disparo ponemos la pelota de ping-pong y
podemos ver que obtuvimos un lanzamiento
exitoso ahora vamos a probarlo afuera
entonces ya tenemos nuestro lanzador de
proyectiles listo y al fondo en el
plástico negro pusimos varios números
para
carla altura y también pusimos un flexo
metro para poder medir las distancias
inicialmente vamos a establecer la
posición número 4 que es la cuarta
posición horizontal y en 20 grados y
podemos ver en donde cae la pelota la
podemos medir en la trampa de arena que
nos permite saber en donde cayó la
pelota ahora vamos a ver qué pasa con 30
grados en la misma posición es decir la
cuarta ahora a 40 grados y estamos
viendo que la pelota está elevándose más
ahora a 50 grados y nuevamente la pelota
se eleva más entonces la distancia que
recorre está disminuyendo y la altura
está aumentando ahora a 60 grados y
conforme vamos más y más arriba la
pelota tiende a desviarse un poco ahora
a 70 grados con la misma posición la
pelota sale completamente de la pantalla
y nuevamente no cae tan lejos
a 80 grados veamos una medición más
precisa para saber exactamente qué tan
alto llega a la pelota la trampa de
arena mide nuestro rango de distancias y
si ralentizamos un poco la grabación
podemos ver que la pelota logró llegar
casi a los 3 pies porque en donde
empieza la hoja son exactamente 3 pies
así que la pelota llegó aproximadamente
a los 2 pies y 10 pulgadas de altura en
ese lanzamiento
vamos a intentar otro ese fue a 20
grados en la posición número 4 y podemos
ver que la pelota llega hasta
aproximadamente los 3 pies y 4 pulgadas
entonces esto nos permite medir la
altura y eso lo podemos usar en nuestros
cálculos ahora veamos si podemos usar
esta información para tirar una torre de
vasos y esta es la posición 4 a 20
grados
y en solo tres intentos